meine tolle kollegin nina schenk hat
sich gerade eben darüber aufgeregt dass
in ihrer heimatstadt düsseldorf künftig
zwei gilt und zwar auch im theater in
der oper und im museum kaiser für
städtische kultureinrichtungen für die
von der stadt die städtischen
kultureinrichtungen ab erster november
also bis dahin können jetzt die umgebung
nach einer kurzen zeit nutzen und dürfen
dann auch mal ins museum aber ab dem
ersten november dann nicht mehr ich muss
dir bei seiner these oder deiner meinung
sehr sehr sehr sehr viel recht geben
denn ich finde dass wir endlich viel
mehr darüber sprechen müssen wenn das
ganze beendet wird die entspannt hat
sich heute versucht hat gesagt die
epidemische lage endet jetzt da kann man
sagen herzlichen glückwunsch auch jens
spahn rechnet mal aufgewacht nach sehr
vielen monaten wo immer noch weiter
panik geschürt würde wurde dass die
zahlen hoch gehen könnten das jetzt
wieder der winter kommen wenn das alles
ganz dramatisch wird also eigentlich
hatte man das gefühl bei einigen
experten und damit meine ich nicht jetzt
nicht karl lauterbach sondern zum
beispiel frau brinkmann und andere hatte
man das gefühl dass wir eigentlich hier
im winter wieder kurz vor allem lockdown
stehen ich finde expertinnen wie frau
bringt man täte gut daran sich für das
was sie da vor wenigen monaten behauptet
haben nämlich dass die zahl nach oben
geht und alles ganz schlimm wird und
dramatisch wird sich jetzt einmal zu
erklären es gab oder sogar zu
entschuldigen es gab ja ganz was
beispiel war in österreich in talkshows
zu gast und da hat mir ein virologe
erzählt dass ein freund von den biologen
in österreich sich entschuldigt hat bei
der bevölkerung als er falsche szenario
aus gemeinde hat sich dafür dann aber
auch entschuldigt was mich ein bisschen
stört ist es gibt es bei uns in
deutschland ja gar nicht alle 10 uhr ach
nein man konnte nichts mehr vorsehen
hier lagern war karl lauterbach hier
herein und
wahrscheinlich schon im vorfeld
entschuldigt habe dass man sich
entschuldigen konnte schneider gesagt
werden ein fehler machen und muss
szenario vom biologen der einfach sagt
liebe kinder es tut mir leid dass ihr
irgendwie so langen locken
ich habe mir geht etwas näher liegendes
durch den kopf jetzt da wir alle
erkennen aufgrund der sehr viel höheren
impfquote als wir angenommen haben dass
das ganze zu ende geht und dass die
große aufregung abebbt und dass die
pandemische notlage beendet wird dann
sollte auch der staat die politik den
mut haben
zweig an öffentlichen plätzen zu
verbieten also zweig das aus meiner
sicht nur im privaten einrichtungen
restaurants bars cafés da ist jeder
inhaber
autonomen das zu verhängen wenn er will
aber an öffentlichen plätzen also soll
man es fehlt nur noch der bahnhof dass
man nicht mal mit der eisenbahn fahren
kann ja aber in theatern und und und
museen usw da zahlt ja der mensch der
nicht rein darf auch noch durch seine
steuern für ohne dass er dann rein darf
das geht überhaupt nicht das muss man
dringend eingrenzen wie jetzt da das
ganze sowieso zu ende geht ich habe mich
gefragt ob wir bei weltmeister im
ausgrenzen werden wollen dass ich mich
wirklich gefragt ob deutschland
irgendwie jetzt eine neue ja wieder
weltmeister werden wollen wenn man in
holland ist wie ich am wochenende keine
maske alles ist gut und hier kommen wen
und debattieren über sowas und ich muss
wirklich sagen diesen zweig regelungen
es ist traurig das ist das ist jetzt
eine stadt von euch getroffen die
heimatstadt hätte ich nämlich die ganze
zeit betont wie gut dass ich aus
düsseldorf stamme hier ist meine eigene
meiner heimatstadt würde man so etwas
nicht machen welche es denn dies liegt
in thüringen nicht aber da sieht man
ganz klar ich finde wir müssen jetzt
eben freedom werden und nicht mehr über
diese zweijährige richtig aber ab erster
november das finde ich auch mal so
lustigen vielleicht kannst du mir klar
du bist viel näher an der politik daran
hat sich ab erster november gilt das
jetzt aber wenn wir doch gerade so ein
horror zustand haben das jetzt verhängt
werden muss warum dann nicht ab heute
was bringt es jetzt bis erster november
ist hab ich noch nie verstanden der
ganzen kommune zeit nie warum vor ort
und meinen zeit haben als virtuelles
laufwerk auf der lotter karten gibt es
wirklich ich glaube es hat tatsächlich
etwas mit den verordnungen zu tun die
erst geschrieben werden müssen und so
weiter und so fort und dann muss ich
sagen in deiner heimatstadt düsseldorf
bin ich politisch jetzt nicht so gut
vernetzt von daher weiß ich nicht was es
da für lokal dann
also man hat ein datum bekommen und dann
ab dann gilt das immer ich fand das
immer merkwürdig wenn es doch gerade so
ein horrorszenario es muss doch ab
sofort geltenden ich finde wir einen
gewissen freiheitlichen anspruch als als
bundesrepublik als deutschland den wir
auch als freiheitliches land wahren
müssen auch gegenüber denjenigen die
sagen ich will mich nicht impfen lassen
es gibt menschen mit vorerkrankungen
abziehen große
angst angst hat sich davor sich im 5 das
weiß ich nicht wissen wie wirkt das bei
mir und unsere justizministerin sagt ja
es wird keine impfpflicht geben das ist
eine impfpflicht durch die hintertür
warum denn bitte nicht wenn ich mich
frei teste und einen aktuellen test
dabei aber er sagt heute mittag war ich
negativ dann ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sie in den letzten sechs stunden
positiv geworden bin auch nicht groß und
größer als durchbruch neben versicherer
weiter steht in meinem rachen als
geimpfte kann genauso wohl wie russland
seien wenig geben flüssigkeit dem ich ja
nicht mehr heißt theoretisch auch weil
rädisch beckens ansteckend auch als gilt
es zum beispiel sicherer als meine
impfung für andere leute vor allem
nehmen diese menschen auch noch aktiv an
der pandemie bekämpfung teilen sie gehen
sich testen das heißt sie sind
involviert sie wollen da gutes tun und
das sind im prinzip dann die die man vor
den kopf stößt also an der stelle wird
es nicht kontrovers werden natürlich
geht das so nicht wenn es ist eine
gesellschaftliche spaltungen in drei
natürlich die impfpflicht wenn ich das
richtig sehe regiert die fdp in
nordrhein-westfalen mit mit der cdu
düsseldorf liegt in nordrhein-westfalen
immer wenn ich heute habt solltet ihr
schon klar aber das ist ja landesrecht
die korona bekämpfung die haben sich ja
nur sozusagen freiwillig zusammengetan
mit ausnahme dieser pandemischen notlage
der verbundes abgeschlossen worden ist
sollte doch mal die nordischen landes
wieder ein akt der freiheit vollziehen
und der stadt düsseldorf verbieten zweig
in öffentlichen plätzen einzuführen aber
habt ihr nicht immerhin der in
städtischen kultureinrichtungen ist aber
eher corona war irgendwie weiter dahin
es gibt jetzt niemanden wir das zentrale
in der hand hält niemand der sagt okay
da geht's lang sondern ist es war hart
und es beschäftigt uns vielleicht noch
ein halbes jahr vielleicht noch ein jahr
vielleicht auch zwei jahre und niemand
macht den an den bedient tatsächlich
geht setzt sich das ziel hier das ganze
für beendet und kurioserweise und gucken
wir bei den sondierungen gar nicht
darauf ob die dazu irgendwas beschlossen
haben wir halt da steht nichts drin
haben die darüber gerät sind warum wir
reden nicht darüber entstehen aber das
müssten sie doch ich meine da ist
jeden bürger jeden 3 ja ja ja wir haben
das fehler gesehen während des
wahlkampfes war einst eines der
wesentlichen themen was die menschen
bewegt hat das wurde nicht debattiert
trotzdem hat im osten sicherlich der afg
solche ergebnisse dieses thema dann lass
uns doch mal darüber sprechen wer weil
das thema so wichtig ist
gesundheitsminister werden könnte wenn
wir viele namen gehandelt
meine these ist olaf scholz will unter
allen umständen verhindern dass das
gesundheitsministerium an ihn geht damit
er nicht karl lauterbach dorthin setzen
da gebe es so viel druck aus der basis
sehe schon zornesfalten mag ist wenn ich
den namen
wie in der fdp über ihrer letzten
regierungsbeteiligung da war erst
philipp rösler gesundheitsminister
daniel bahr also sie haben so ein
bisschen erfahrung durchaus in dem
bereich wäre das ein ministerium was sie
gerne hätten in dieser zeit wie sie hat
mich schon zum finanzministerium nicht
geäußert da ging es um meinen chef
werden anderen material spiele
ein bisschen spannender
die fdp will das ministerium nicht
willes gesundheit ja will sie nicht aus
angst vor der nächsten party hat sie hat
anderes im auge sind
es gibt ja vermutlich an
digitalisierungs minister viel
spannender ist wird auch immer es kann
und ich bei gesundheit haben sie schon
mehrfach die finger verbrannt die fdp
also und die die spd will den lauterbach
nicht sie könnte kaum an ihm vorbeigehen
sie hat vermutlich sechs minister drei
davon sind frauen bleiben drei männer da
ist schon mal herr heil arbeit und
soziales dann erklingen weil das hoffe
ich sogar verteidigung finde ich auch
gut
dann könnte er wie heißt der
niedersächsische innenminister
wieso ist es gibt natürlich nicht weil
du drei niedersachsen für die
haben sie viele männer aus der drei
frauen sind ja schon abgezogen
du hast aber vergessen dass es olaf
scholz gibt den kanzleramtsminister wolf
gerechnet das sind dann schon zwei
männer das heißt es bleiben eigentlich
nur noch zwei ministerien können ich
halte die wochen ist vorläufig vorbei
guckte die cdu an was da los ist sind
alle nrw kandidaten die männer ja ja ja
aber jetzt erzählen sie mal ein bisschen
aus dem nähkästchen
ihren an der stelle ich wirklich die
replik geben dass ich natürlich sehr
wohl ich glaube dass wir gute leute
haben die jedes minister aber wir haben
sie doch einmal dass sie zumindest den
anspruch erheben das
technologieministerium führen zu wollen
als technologieexperte ein dann war das
einladungsmanagement natürlich
hersteller vor allem auch das werde ich
nicht aber ich habe wirklich mein gefühl
ist ich mache mir fernseher an und
schauen also fdp unserer sind zum vater
sich langweilig geworden also auch jetzt
sein leben wenn er jetzt in interviews
ist es so präsidial und toll und alles
wird wahnsinnig gemütlich und so wo ist
da die sprache dann irgendwann kubicki
würde jetzt zwar aus damit ich natürlich
dass das für presse schaffen dann
natürlich nicht lässt sich um ein paar
einfachen wlan auch nicht genauso ich
glaube nicht dass man uns gewählt hat um
irgendwie presseartikel zu produzieren
und abend formate zu führen ich glaube
die leute wollen dass sich das land
verändert und dass wir das ernst nehmen
und mir sind der dinge angeschrieben
angesprochen wurden vorhergehende
regierungen und regierungs bildungs
versuche und insofern ist es ganz normal
dass sowohl die einzelnen personen ich
bin jetzt aus zweiten mal wiedergewählt
man sieht dinge anders hier geht es
jetzt auch um eine regierung das ist
keine andere seriosität wiener
opposition ganz einfach und ich glaube
das ist das gebot der stunde und
verstehe dass es natürlich dass für
dieses format hier von nachteil ist aber
das ist so simpel ist nicht unser
primäres ich sage voraus dass er sicher
ist ja diese haltung aber ich sage
voraus dass wir nicht lange werden
warten müssen bis diese inhaltliche
bestimmung auch durch indiskretionen
dann und anstand hat mich was wird aus
aufgang kubicki bin ich häufig richtern
ministerposten der vereinschef günter
werden oder er wird fraktionschef ist
ein du hast du fragen über die
fraktionspräsidenten ich glaube das ist
zwischen ich glaube die geschichte die
hat ihm sehr geschadet also respekt für
dieses wunderbare interview aber während
des wahlkampfs so eine sache raus zu
hauen wie er gesagt hat dass er gesagt
hat ich habe quasi unterlaufen und bela
das hat in vielen städten gebracht
als andrea das war
schade und nicht so wenig waschen ich
glaube nicht so dumpf wobei ich glaube
dass jede partei ein man braucht ja auch
die wahrheiten des volkes so ausspricht
der itan also auch noch mal
kritik mein tipp geht zu den grünen okay
wenn ich bei der das halten wir fest für
eine der nächsten sendung
[Musik]